you may not become a big shot you may
not have a half a billion dollars worth
of real estate to worry about like I do
but everybody needs to be in real estate
in some aspect of their life everybody
times are not good in real estate that's
just a fact but once it starts bleeding
that's when it starts gushing you know
my life's going to be over I already
used up uh at least 75% of my life you
know the real scary part is a lot of
your friends start getting seriously ill
and they start passing away and that
scares you because um you know you're
going to be one of
them have you noticed any benefits of
cigarette smoking like nicotine being in
your system because there are some
studies that show nicotine increases
mental acuity it increases energy levels
Focus Etc or is it just
negative it's highly addictive that's
number one you know that that that's
that's just a known fact listen I've
been smoking for I'm embarrassed to say
45 years my lungs are clear I had
everything checked I don't know effects
I know people that don't smoke get lung
cancer figure that out you know it's
it's crazy I got a poor manager and
she's dying right now throat cancer and
she didn't smoke do they know what
caused throat cancer cancer is a weird
thing you know but um I can tell you
this um I enjoy it somehow call it like
an addiction maybe it's the addiction
that makes think I'm enjoying it but in
the
morning I can't get rocking and roll and
without coffee and a cigarette or two
it's just something that I'm not ready
to give up you know I don't know maybe
it's just the addictive addictive uh
being addicted to nicotine I don't know
but it has a lot of bad things I know
you know that that that you know that it
does to you um like you know maybe
shortness of breath things like that but
I think you know overweight does too but
um the point is it's part of my
lifestyle it may not work for you and
that's fine you know but you know I
don't what does it what does it feel
like though to smoke a cigarette it
gives you some sort of high but not like
a weird high like the drugs you do um
you know it gives you some kind of uh I
don't know if you could live without it
it's probably a lot better for you to
live without it but I grew up on it and
um seems like you're cutting back though
right like I've noticed you're losing
weight and you're smoking less right
definitely cut back go getting old you
know you start thinking about oh you
know my life's going to be over I
already used up uh at least 75% of my
life I'm you know so I'm not going to be
here there going to be a lot of years
you're going to be here and I'm not you
know you start thinking about that when
you start approaching I'm 58 I just
turned 58 you start approaching that 60
Mark you start thinking and you know the
real scary part is a lot of your friends
start getting seriously ill and they
start passing away and that scares the
idea because um you know you're going to
be one of them yeah have you had an
instance have you had an instance that
really changed your mindset like I said
you know I've been seeing a lot of
friends having health issues and um it's
really got me thinking you know no none
of us are going to be here forever we
all know that I mean you know best case
scenario you're going to drop Deb
between 70 and 100 okay so can I prolong
that and then who wants to be old and
all broken down and you know a bunch of
stuff from you what kind of quality of
life is that so you know when you start
becoming hitting that 60 Mark you really
start thinking about the quality of your
life and the longevity of your life I
mean it's just it's life you know we're
all only going to be here for a little
while you know and then after you're
gone let's face it you're gone yeah I
mean even the most famous people in the
world they're gone all right you know
you have some memories of you and things
like that and depending on how famous
you were Michael Jackson people remember
him forever was presly things like that
but you're dead all right it's over this
might sound more bit are you afraid of
death yes everyone's afraid of death I
don't care who you are so how does how
does that affect your decisions today I
mean I've been thinking about what's
going to happen to my
family um you know and people close to
me if I'm not around all right so I'm
I'm really thinking to others I mean
yeah I mean I think about myself of
course on a daily basis while I'm here
but I'm think
holy you know all right yeah my
wife's probably going to find some young
guy and have a great life
but with all the money she's going to n
but I mean I start thinking about you
know protecting everyone when I'm not
here you know kids wives friends
everybody like that so it's part of life
it's part of Being Human you know we're
only on this planet for you know a
certain amount of time so do everything
you can while you're here and enjoy it
and try to protect the people that are
going to be here after you so for those
watching who are not familiar with you
and your story could you give us a a
highlevel overview of who you are why
people should listen to you what you do
just something for a few minutes you
know my story is started from nothing
less than nothing I mean you know and
had no opportunity no chance I was in
the Army you know I went in the Army
because I had to because you know
growing up in New York City was very
tough and uh the Army was my exit out of
New York away from surrounded by a
criminal uh atmosphere which was really
bad back in the 19 late 70s and 80s and
I went in the Army you know that got me
out of New York it got me in a you know
an organized control atmosphere gave me
discipline gave me organizational
organizational skills um it showed me
you know the real you know how how the
world works okay working with people
getting things done accomplishing your
missions uh and it really helped me and
saved my life because if I didn't go in
the army I guarantee I'd be dead maybe
if I was lucky rotting away in some jail
okay because that was just the place I
was born into you're a product of your
environment I mean it's very hard to
fight your environment when you're
surrounded by it you know I spent about
five years in the Army and then while I
was in my last year of the army um I
started I lived in an apartment building
where pretty much everybody was in the
military you know they lived there in
and you know off the base so I got an
opportunity to help the manager out it
was an old lady and I picked up garbage
every single morning I'd get up just
like we did in the Army and police the
area you know what that means police the
area means look for papers garbage
whatever's not natural get rid of it so
anyway I policed the whole building
clean the place up and I'd get $50 a
month off my rent my rent was $500 a
month I got I only had to pay 450 to me
that believe it or not 50 bucks back in
we're talking
1986 86 887 it meant something okay
basically that's how I got got my start
I did a little real estate in leasing
while I was in Germany I was stationed
in Germany and there was not enough
housing for all the soldiers so the
soldiers had to go out and what they
called the economy where the Germans
lived and secure uh you know place to
live for them or the families and then
the Army would pay you x amount of
dollars towards a housing allowance so
what I did was I hooked up with a guy
that I used to find a place off
base and I hooked up with the guy and
then I would bring him soldiers that
needed a place to rent so he'd have the
the German uh Apartments I had the
soldiers and every time I brought him a
soldier back back then I think he gave
me like 150 bucks which was a lot of
money back then especially in Germany
the German Mark was like 4 to one or
something like that so anyway you I've
been a hustler my whole life growing up
in New York you learn how to hustle
because I mean that's all you can do I
mean you know um and I did it at a very
young age so I was already into hustling
I did some hustling in Germany um then I
got to the states and then like I said I
started picking up garbage around the
building and I started really
understanding real estate you know it's
not very difficult and I try to explain
that to people real estate is very
simple all right you're providing either
a person a place to live a business to
operate in and they pay your rent okay
it's a very simple uh Arrangement that
you have um so basically I liked it you
know people would move out I'd help them
get the apartments ready um we get
things fixed when they break you're
basically maintaining the property and
then they pay your rent and you
constantly got to keep the place full
you know so you can get the most money
coming in one thing I learned about real
estate always focus on getting as much
money coming in and as little money
going out okay because it's all about
the bottom line and I try to just tell
people and help people listen everybody
needs to be in real estate in some
aspect of their life everybody okay
because it's a necessity everybody needs
a place to live everybody needs a place
to work okay it real estate is part of
life okay um we all can't live in a tent
like you used to before you make G you
know and everybody should definitely try
to establish something you may not
become a big shot you may not have a
half a billion dollars worth of real
estate to worry about like I do but it
needs to play some sort of role in your
life and the more you put into it the
more you will make but before we go into
that you probably can't go anywhere
without hearing the term Ai and that's
because it's probably the most important
computer technology ever we use it here
on the iced coffee hour behind the
scenes like a a lot with all these great
things considered the real problem with
AI is that you need a lot of speed and
processing power so how can you compete
without the cost getting completely out
of hand well it's time to upgrade to the
next generation of the cloud Oracle
Cloud infrastructure or oci oci is a
single platform for your infrastructure
database application development and AI
needs oci offers four to eight times the
bandwidth of other competing clouds they
offer one consistent price rather than
variable Regional pricing like their
competitors and of course Nobody Does it
Better Than Oracle so now you can train
your AI models at twice the speed and
less than half of the cost of other
clouds so if you want to do more and
spend less like uber 8 by8 and datab
Bricks Mosaic take the free test drive
of oci at oracle.com that's oracle.com
sisted once again guys oracle.com isted
thank you so much Oracle for supporting
this podcast and allowing us to do what
we do and with that said let's get back
to the episode when did you go from
being like casually interested in real
estate and it kind of just being like a
hobby SL passion to oh my gosh I could
end up having like half a billion
dollars in real estate because there has
to be a switch there where like okay
this is something I can make money in
versus this is something I am
competitively extremely good at and I
can actually build a fortune we did it
for me was when I met the owner of the
building that was you know I was living
in getting 50 bucks bu off my rep I met
the
owner the owner was a great guy smart
guy but he wasn't will to work that hard
I mean I'm sorry he was a great guy we
ended up becoming Partners the point was
is that I saw how he was living he was
living good and I liked real estate
because I just felt like it's something
that I felt you know how you like stuff
or you don't really care for it you know
my father always told me just become a
garbage man okay you be outdoors all day
you get good benefits you get a pension
you know that was the extent of you know
my father you know expectations for me
were that was his advice
anyway the point was I saw this guy
driving Ferraris I saw this guy driving
Mercedes I saw this guy living in fancy
houses I saw this guy traveling around
the
world
and what happened was I started making
him more money because I looked at real
estate and thought of ways to make him
more money and when you start and when
you can find someone like I tell people
when you're starting out find somebody
that's making money all right and be
their support
because if you start helping him make
more money you become
Irreplaceable and I became Irreplaceable
to him okay actually the Army wanted me
to reinlist for another four years and
they were going to give me some bonus
and this and that and I told him hey I
got to go I'm going to Career he said no
no no you're not going nowhere I'm going
to pay you more than the Army and we're
going to we're going to do stuff
together we're going to grow and you're
going to be a
multi-millionaire and a lot of that of
course came true you know but I did a
lot of it on my own besides what I do
with him yeah but how did he get a
Ferrari and get the travel and all that
stuff he if he wasn't a hard worker did
he like inherit all the real estate some
people work hard some people work smart
he was a smart worker he he he knew a
lot about Banking and um I think he also
you know he his family you know gave him
some money to work with and um let's
face it real estate is not brain
science okay I never went one day to
high
school I mean real estate is a very
simple business okay it can get complex
as you go down the road and you grow but
the basics of real estate is simple okay
and everything is based on math
everything's based on what is what is
the value of it all right and is there a
demand for your supply everything in the
world is supply and demand I don't care
what you want to sell in Life or what
you have for offer somebody a service
it's all about Supply supply and demand
all right you want to have a supply of
what's in demand okay and in real estate
you got to make sure you never buy
something you don't want to have a
supply of what's not in demand like look
at office space right now office bait's
getting crushed why because we've
evolved we're into technology uh Co
taught us a lot about you know you could
work remotely big companies are
shrinking down what space they had or
they're just totally giving it up I mean
you know the office sector luckily I'm
not in is taking a major beating right
now okay so you want to always focus on
supply and demand guys tell me all the
time oh I can build a storage place and
storage business is a great business but
you don't want to buy it where people
don't need it You' be sitting around a
bunch of empty storage yeah you know
what does your portfolio look like today
today we're sitting on a very large
portfolio of what I like to call
necessity real estate or essential real
estate I like retail but I like retail
that the internet can't hurt Amazon
can't hurt I like you know food I like
you know necessity services like hair
nails food you know good strong
restaurants dentist medical uh things
that people can't go online and
accomplish okay that's the type of
retail I like I try to stay away from
the big um retail is like department
stores I had opportunities to buy
shopping malls and I didn't do it
because I was afraid of them
um but I like this stuff like you know
who's doing really well believe it who
made it through all the storms is the
discount um type of department stores
okay we own we own Ross we own TJ Maxx
we own Burlington's we own those types
because the discount stuff it's not like
you can't go online and really get a lot
of discount stuff you can go online and
buy whatever you want but if you're
looking for the discounted stuff you got
to go to the store and do it because you
never know what they're getting in and
people like to try stuff on so you know
we stick to the necessity type retail
yeah we're also in the hotel business
okay hotels are all based on location we
just sold a hotel in Fort Lauderdale I
think we ended up selling for only 28
million I thought it was going to be
worth 35 but what happened the hotel was
a corporate Hotel it was literally in a
Corporate Park you know with office
building surrounding it those Office
Buildings are empty now okay and you
can't just imagine you know easily
create business in a situation like that
you know so I felt that you know the
place still needed a lot more money put
into it to accomplish um what the
franchise wanted us to do there was
probably still at least three to4
million that need to be pumped into the
place to bring it up to you know the
franchise standards it just didn't and
it was too far from my home my kids were
out there running it I just said you
know what we got to sell this asset I
don't see the the light at the end of
the tunnel yeah how much was it making
it was doing okay but it wasn't doing
what it could have done or should have
done when I bought it when I bought it
the offices were full okay and then
covid came and destroyed everything so
you know but there was other local
investors that felt that they could do
some marketing and um they could improve
the business there and I wish them the
best of luck and I'm sure they'll be you
know they'll be successful I mean they
bought it at a good price and it was a
great hotel but you know you got to you
got you got to choose which assets
you're really want to put your heart
stolen money into okay and when you
think this this this hotel is not going
to take you uh to the end of the the pot
of gold at the end uh that quickly at
least you got to move on and find a deal
at will so we kind of got out of Fort
Lauderdale now we're still sitting with
about a half a dozen hotels in my area
where I'm close to and I can you know we
also have Benz hotels.com if you're
coming to the Tampa Bay area we have a
place for you to stay okay on all
different types
Ben's Hotel so it's all the hotels you
own if you go to Ben hotels.com it'll
show you every hotel I have it'll show
you the ones by the Tampa Airport it'll
show you the ones that are along to Gulf
of Mexico by The Beach it'll show you
the ones in high traffic tourist areas
whatever our portfolio hotels is they're
at Benz hotels.com and I try to always
buy in the affordable you know I try to
have affordable hotels okay I'm not
doing four or five star hotels all right
because it's just not our for
yeah okay and it's a great for the
people that are doing it but we like to
we're across the street from the beach
so you go where I live you've been in my
town you go on the sand and you could
spend $500 a night for a room or you
could go across the street right across
the street and stay in my hotel for less
than half maybe only 200 yeah you know
we give people an affordable product you
know so there's a need for all different
types of you know clients and we try to
fill the need of the people that you
know looking for a break you know they
don't have that kind of big money to go
out and spend on a vacation especially a
family you know yeah so that's our
little thing what what are you finding
with Airbnb is there's a lot of
controvery with Airbnb whether that be
taking off the market driving up the
housing uh but you are competing almost
with hotels so you're a competitor to
Airbnb what are your thoughts on that
there's a certain Market of people that
like Airbnb
unfortunately I I do a lot of Consulting
and a lot of people have been calling me
lately unfortunately saying hey they
bought airbnbs and their rights to rent
them were taken away by the local local
municipalities I mean they're ruined
they overpaid for the property it's not
worth they buy so they're buying these
properties I thought a lot of the
airbnbs are just subleasing they lease
from the landlord and then put it on
Airbnb and Profit the difference but to
buy an Airbnb is stupid bought condos a
lot of people own houses and now listen
you're running an Airbnb you're running
a little mini mini Hotel you know and it
all depends you know are you running it
is your host running it you know there's
still a lot of work to be done the money
you're making on Airbnb you're earning
if you're the one to renting them out
and coordinating with the guests and
getting the cleaning done and getting
the repairs done you know if if not
there's a cost in paying somebody listen
everything can work if you buy something
right you got to buy it at the right
price you buy things at the right price
and you you should always be successful
so you know but Airbnb I think it had
its big boom it's still going to always
be around and it it took a lot of money
out of the hotel business that's a fact
okay but I think it's gone down and you
got to be very careful in investing in
them so what do you tell people if they
bought a property for Airbnb they're
losing a ton of money they can't rent it
out anymore and they can't cash flow it
by renting it on a normal lease what do
you tell them what's your advice I mean
everybody body's got a different
situation the first thing I would say
listen can you get out of it at a break
even can you sell that property maybe
there's been some appreciation in that
particular housing market in that area
what's the property worth if you put it
on the market tomorrow how much did you
pay for it okay and if you are going to
take a loss what is that loss compared
to the loss you're going to have sitting
on it for another year not making any
money you know you got to look at every
factor of the whole equation and then
maybe you have some gain somewhere else
we can offset some losses listen I just
sold a whole bunch of stock and I was
very unhappy about it because it's the
end of the year and my account and said
listen in 2023 even though things were
bad you made some money okay you sold
some properties you got some major gains
here you need to take some losses so I
had to sit down and I just said okay
well the only place I didn't get any
losses at is sell off some of the stock
that's been beating down 20 and 30% I
could always buy it back after 31 days
you know that you know that you could
sell something like let's say I sold a
whatever M mutual fund the other day I
sold it I think it was about 20% down
which I think is a great time to buy now
but I'm already in it I sold it I took
the loss so now I get all the loss I had
all right let's say it was a million
bucks if i s if it was a million dollars
when I bought it and I got a $200,000
loss on it now I could sell it I take
the $200,000 loss to offset $200,000
worth
gains and then if I really think it's
it's a you know it's going to come back
and I can buy it back 31 days later and
here I am in the same boat with the
$200,000 uh loss that I took and
$200,000 on a capital gain is pretty
much $40,000 in taxes that I would had
to pay the government I mean these are
the things you got to think about
everybody's got their own Investments
their own situation you got to do what's
logical everything's based on logic in
my brain but before we go into that Guys
these cameras they were like $4,000 a
piece the lenses were like 2 Grand these
cables the audio recording devices the
microphones everything adds up and this
whole setup is incredibly expensive and
it makes my pockets and my brain hurts
so badly but the thing is you don't have
to start like that like when we first
started the podcast you could look back
at our first episodes horrible it was
awful but if you want to get started
with content creation our sponsor
streamyard is there to help and make it
as easy as possible streamyard is a live
streaming software that allows you to
create highquality content with just the
click of a button I know you guys listen
to this podcast every single Sunday and
a lot of you guys want to create a
podcast for yourself if that's you I
strongly recommend you guys do it and if
you do I strongly recommend you guys try
streamyard they also allow you to stream
to multiple social media platforms all
at the same time to maximize your
Outreach from Facebook to Instagram to
uh Link Link LinkedIn we got everything
guys we're doing LinkedIn we got we got
LinkedIn
that's and the best part from all of
this when you use our link it's
absolutely free they offer a free
package it means it cost you absolutely
nothing to get started with our link
Down Below in the description so if you
guys want to get started creating
highquality content at the cost of
virtually nothing try out streamyard
with the link Down Below in the
description thank you so much streamyard
for supporting this podcast and back to
the show do you try to live off of
income that certain things can generate
or do you ever borrow against that
because what I heard that I like like
years AO go that explained how wealthy
people avoid paying taxes is like in
stocks they just continually invest in
that and then you can borrow against the
stock portfolios then you just end up
paying whatever interest fees that you
borrow you can borrow against anything
you can borrow against any asset you
have that has some sort of value to it I
mean typically what I did we created my
wealth was pretty much based on the
1031 you know deferred tax exchange that
the IRS laws have okay every time I I
had a property I improved it and I went
and I increased the value in it I would
refinance it I would either refinance it
because that's a non-t taxable event
okay pull my money out of it and still
cash flow the ultimate goal to me has
always been in real estate is you buy
something you improve it okay now it's
worth more money then you get your money
back so now I have nothing invested in
my property but I still cash flow what
kind of return is that infinite so now
here I am I'm sitting with all these
properties that I refinanced I got all
my money back so I can deploy in other
deals or whatever spend it and I'm still
cash flowing and that's great I own
businesses real estate without any money
invested or if you sell it because you
have to look at is it the right thing to
do and once you refinance and you pull
your money out all right I'm sitting
here with this property and it's giving
me a good cash flow
but everything is timing when the market
goes up there might be even more value
in it and then again also when you
refinance the property the most you're
going to get is 80% of the value there's
still 20% of the value is still sitting
there so now I might decide all right I
want to move I want to raise cash I want
to do some bigger deals I might sell it
but if I sell it I've always 1031 into
the next deal for over 30 years I've
been doing that I never touch the money
from a sale the money gets reinvested Ed
into the next deal and that kind of
forced me to grow but then don't you
have some like crazy tax burdens of like
let's say 30 years eventually or
something like that where down the line
it could get sold what happens is your
basis gets stepped up gets decreased
every time you the the taxes you defer
are counted against your basis so yes if
I sell that deposit you were talking
about for 20 something million tomorrow
my basis is probably only about eight so
then if I don't 1031 I will have to
recapture $12 million worth of gain
which would be million $25 million tax
bill and at my age I might be prepared
to do that luckily I haven't done it yet
I haven't paid that that tax bill
because luckily I have sons that work
with me so I keep exchanging with their
help in the other deals now of course
it's like the mafia you don't get out
there you die when you die your wife
gets stepped up bases there are some
trust that I believe that also can get
that benefit but I'm working on looking
into that right now but the limit to
that isn't that like $24 million on the
Step Up in basis through inheritance
yeah yeah I don't think it's any
anywhere close to that is is it is it
different if if you give a property to
your wife at passing does everything get
stepped up or is it up to the believe
your wife and only your wife can inherit
everything you have with stepped up
bases but we need to verify if that's
the case everyone should make sure they
marry
younger everyone and then you just don't
then you just don't pay the that's genus
I mean I'm working on it gets
complicated when you're starting to plan
your death it gets very complicated you
need really good advice from really good
trust attorneys I feel like that that
wouldn't be the case because then if you
want to give a property to someone else
you just marry that person before dying
to and have a trust have everything
stepped up and then they could sell
without paying tax and then distribute
the money that seems like too easy of us
they can only distribute the money to a
point too I think right now you can you
can um you're allowed to I believe it's
still like 11 point something million
that you can uh gift yes life time is 11
something million okay so me and my wife
can give together right now 24 million
if we wanted to um but you know like I
said I'm not an expert in trust and
things like that I'm I'm actually
looking for people to consult with on
that but I mean let me tell you the
worst case in the world is this all
right if I look at my whole portfolio if
I got a half a billion bucks in in real
estate let's say I ow a bank half of
that I owe them 250 million and let's
say the rest of the other 250 million I
got to give basically 20% of that that's
50 million I'm still up for 200
million I think I'll be doing okay why
don't why don't you just do that and
just spend the rest of your life
definitely definitely thinking about
that now you know but then I'm also have
to consider you know what's best for not
only me but what's best for all the kids
I got and the people that are important
in my life yeah but 200 goes a long way
200 million right now will get you if
you're sticking in taxfree immunity
bonds it's going to get you roughly
about 10 plus million a year taxfree tax
free that's really almost like you know
my bracket 37% you know you know we're
talking if here in California was almost
double you know so
I mean you know everybody's got their
own life and you have to plan you have
to plan your life and you have to make
you know certain moves that are logical
and make the most sense for your life so
right now I'm trying to figure it out
that's why I'm here today Jack's going
to tell me exactly what to do is that
and then I'm going to do the opposite is
is that where you're at uh like about
$500 million in assets $250 million in
liabilities I believe so it's right
about there but then last time we had
you on the podcast we discussed that you
did a lot of deals with variable rates
when rates really low because like you
said this is your words not mine that
you're being a little bit greedy trying
to get like the best possible discounted
rate so to save a little bit of money
but it ended up when rates went up you
had that float rate or variable rate and
you basically when I used to owe about a
couple hundred million I could have paid
an extra point and fixed my
rate that extra point would have cost me
$2 million a year right oh okay yeah
instead now I'm paying and an
extra three points at least so now I'm
paying extra six million a year when I
could have got away with paying two
million back then now how long did I get
away without paying that two million
probably a couple of years I don't know
I have to look it up a few years I mean
listen no one in their right mind in the
30 years I've been in real estate would
ever dream that rates would go up so
high so quick never has ever been seen
before okay but right now we're sitting
back where rates were're at in 2007 I
believe right before the crash and what
does that mean we may not have a major
crash but we're definitely going to have
a major correction and there's going to
be opportunity all right yes I'm well
protected Capital wise uh where I can I
can handle you know the stress that we
we're paying out all this extra money in
interest payments luckily we're strong
capitalized and we can handle it plus
we're doing all kinds of different
things to adjust but a lot of people
can't and a lot of the people that can't
a lot of the people that pulled together
because nobody wants to make Capital
calls nobody wants to come out of their
pocket and start buying down debt and
throwing more money into a deal that's
why you know it gets tricky when you're
involved in a group so you know there's
going to be some very very bad things I
believe happening with bankruptcies with
foreclosures uh in the next year coming
in a matter of a couple of months I
think you're going to start hearing
about it uh I don't think the banks
really want you to know right
now all the loans that aren't performing
I thought a lot of these loans have
escalation Clauses essentially so it
can't just go from 3% to eight it'll go
from three to let's say four and a half
and then after that it'll go five and a
half but over long period of time
documents okay you know it depends on
loan documents but typically in my
experience we're not talking residential
the guy goes out he fixed his rate at
two or 3% for his house he's great he's
good he's golden for 30 years 20 years
whatever his loan is but in the
commercial World commercial loans don't
go out that far you can do some
government stuff and some agency loans
that may go out 10 15 years typically
people in the most people in the
commercial business Banks loan money on
Commercial assets for three five 7 and
10 okay so the guy that went out uh
three years ago and got a loan basically
an adjustable loan like I did it was
doing great even if he fixed his rate
three years are up he's open to the
current market okay he's subed to
current market and when he goes out to
have that property appraise now because
of the today's interest rate he's not
going to praise for the same value okay
because the numbers aren't going to make
sense with the interest rate being
double and triple so the value of the
properties have come down listen we were
just talking about it you used to have
to pay four you used to get a four cap
on a Starbucks okay I'm seeing if for 6
six and a half now okay everything
adjusts accordingly cap rates are going
up it's just it's logical you know if
you're only collecting x amount of
dollars a month you can only you know
and you got to pay the bank x amount of
dollars you're only left with this much
return so the property is only value
based on a return so who's buying right
now 1031 buyers unless you know I only
see the only deal I really see going on
right now is people that sold their
properties took the gain you know
because they they had a lot of equity in
their property and a lot of upside and
they want to get out or they want to you
know trade out I mean let's face it you
know real estate's not forever you know
I mean yeah it can be generational you
know but typically people buy properties
they own them for a while and eventually
they sell them I mean you know so sooner
or later somebody's going to want to
sell and you're going to want to get the
hand in the cash you don't want to
retire a lot of people pass away it's
part of life um you know a lot of
Partnerships dissolve a lot of them have
uh a specific amount of time that the
partnership has to sell um you know so
there's always going to be deals to be
made always and the deals are coming so
I'm telling everybody to stash your cash
because when the deals start coming you
want to be up there in line first in
line with your money ready to go line up
your financing and listen interest rates
are double so what does that mean to
really make the numbers work you're
going to have to put up more money
you're going to have to borrow less
money for the bank if I go out right now
and buy down half my debt if I go to the
bank tomorrow and say okay here's 100
million bucks I'm buying down all these
properties by half my cash flow will go
back to what it used to be because I'm
only borrowing you know half the money
at a double rate but then again I got to
come up with that cash which is probably
sitting earning 5% right now so you know
like I said everybody's got their own
portfolio you got to sit down and you
got to look at every single scenario
there is and figure out what makes the
most sense because if it makes sense it
makes money but when is this going to
happen because I honestly thought this
was going to happen way sooner no and
we're not seeing anything at least here
in Vegas Camp rates are going up so
property values are coming down slightly
but it's barely anything and it's to the
point where I'm questioning myself
thinking Am I Wrong is this ever going
to happen it's going to happen has to
happen it's logic that that has to
happen the problem is is that the
sellers including myself don't want to
swallow the
fact that their property is not worth
what they thought it was and it's simple
math the Lowe's that I own you know what
Lowe's is right it's it's a like a Home
Depot I own Home Depot too those
properties I can't get what I paid for
them because I bought them at low cap
rate it's just not going to happen now
am I willing to take a loss no I'm not
willing to take a loss so everybody's
like in a limbo right now everybody that
owns commercial property is you got to
wait for the bleeding to start and it
and it takes a little while for the
bleeding to start okay but once it
starts bleeding that's when it starts
gushing let's just say what happens in a
scenario where where you think there's
going to be blood in the streets but
let's just assume by June of 2024 the
FED says we're lowering interest rates
we're taking them down you know 50 basis
points 75 basis points whatever it is
interest rates start coming down then by
2025 all of a sudden we're at three and
a half% isn't that going to save the
market so maybe there's a chance that
nothing much is going to happen only the
really distressed sellers are going to
sell but they're going to be outliers
you know none of us have a crystal ball
but for my experience real estate's
always been a cycle okay it's always
been a cycle and you just have to know
when the time is right because you'll
see it okay if you go on 10x right now a
year ago there was nothing on 10x
nothing barely nothing crap now you're
starting to see serious assets all over
the country 10x is booming with auctions
hotels they're dying why because people
don't have the money anymore to spend
okay hotels are getting crushed right
now if you're not in a hot spot where
you can keep those rooms filled I could
buy
hotels really cheap right now but
there's a reason why because then I
bring it into money and the cost of
employment has gone up and uh you know
so you know you're going to start seeing
some blood I believe and I'm not you
know I'm not out with crystal ball I
think we got to wait to see this year
end I think when 24 comes and then we
also got a lot of politics have a lot to
do with it okay I think with the current
Administration we just really not going
in the right direction and we're not
going to go in the right direction and
get lower interest rates until we see a
change in government now what do you
what do you think the current president
is doing about a lot of this that that's
bad for the real estate market I'm not
an e economic expert but all I could say
is before he was
president I think the economy and the
world was in a lot better place I mean
I'm just telling you from my life
experience interest rates were low there
was some sort of Peace in the world I
think we're in a lot better shape okay
and that's that's basically my life
experience uh I think that the Democrats
just don't understand uh or they don't
like taking any they're trying to
they're not Risk
Takers okay and I don't know the level
of risk we were approaching when when we
had low interest rates I'm sure there's
some sort of story behind it that it
could hurt us down the road but BAS
basically all I could say is I was
living good and now I'm 5 million bucks
a year in the ho now how much of that
though is Trump lowered taxes gave
businesses a whole bunch of
deductions and he really pressured the
FED to lower interest rates so how much
of the economy was really just there's
more money flowing into the economy
business owners were making a lot more
money and taxes were lower so do you
think maybe that's more of like a
shortterm sort of deal where if we
lowered taxes 10% now I think we'd have
a similar benefit I don't know how we
were getting hurt were we raising the
deficit is that the problem is that what
you know all the good times we're
bringing we're raising the deficit I
mean I heard on on the news the other
day that we only collect I think two
trillion dollar a year in taxes but it
takes how much to run the country I
think it was five or six no I think it
was like five or six but they collect
four I think there was a$2 to three
trillion dollar a year deficit and
that's just being added to the national
debt with rates as high as they are now
I think now the national debt is costing
more than
defense so it's it now I think it's a
game of chicken of how long could that
continue before eventually they got to
lower rates or they got to come out of
pocket a ton of
money well I know one thing it's a known
fact that mortgages at are an all-time
low right people aren't buying homes
right now and I
think that's the that's like the
foundation of people's lives being able
to work and and and buy a home for your
family and have some quality of life I
think is very very important and it's
almost really much impossible for an
average middle class person now to go
out and buy a property to live in so you
know I don't know I I don't think it's
good and then the banks aren't making
any money let's face it the banks aren't
making any money right now the banks are
paying you 5 a half% in money market
account right they got to pay out a lot
of money and then nobody's getting loans
at seven so the bank is just sitting
there basically it's going to hurt the
banks if they don't lower the interest
rates and people don't stop borrowing
money we saw what happened in Silicon
Valley not too long ago okay it's going
to get ugly I think that you know I kind
of track the
foreclosures and uh I also track uh
non-performing loans
and um it's growing it's growing
dramatically right now and the banks
don't want nobody to know because if
word gets out they they're not
collecting on the loans they
had then the banks not the banks only
worth what the loans are the bank's
value is the amount of loans that they
have that's their assets and if they're
not making money on those assets those
assets fall down in value so the bank
ain't worth as much as the bank used to
be worth and the stock goes down and
then we saw what happened in Silicon
Valley they went belly up we saw a lot
of banks go I don't you're too young to
remember
but how many banks went Belly Up in the
crash what about not Banks look at all
the look what happened to the all the
big uh stock Brokers that went Belly Up
Leman Brothers yeah they were around for
a hundred years and you know and they
were upside down yeah mainly because of
Leverage so if you think it's going to
get worse why not preemptively start
selling more aggressively now
I have to determine if it makes sense to
take the losses I have to start looking
at my gains and looking at what the
benefit is to take losses or is it more
beneficial to me to just buy down my
debt you know it's an equation
everything's an equation you said that
you're going to do it like this huge
internal audit with this like quote
unquote really smart guy that's in New
York right now analyzing all of your
Holdings seeing which ones are going to
be good which ones aren't going to be
good are you literally just doing
exactly what you just mentioned to
Graham where it's like you are assessing
how much it costs on a month-to-month
basis how much are you making on a
month-to-month basis and then what is
the opportunity cost of holding it
versus selling it and you're doing that
with every single property every single
asset I have every single one how many
are there 25 okay they're all different
levels you know we have some deals as
small as you know maybe a couple of
million we have deals that you know
maybe are worth 40 million you know it
depends on the asset and then um you
know certain assets like the hotels are
tricky because with the hotel income you
have to look at hotels annually because
Hotel income is a roll it's like a
roller coaster you got your Seasons so
now here we are we're right now in in a
slow season right before the holidays is
always the slowest season in Florida we
probably have hotels that are barely
breaking even but when the good times
come they're going to make a lot of
money so you have to look at it on an
annual basis
some properties I could just strictly
look at on a monthly basis like if it's
a triple net triple Nets are easy to
look at you got the same money coming in
you have very little of anything coming
out because it's triple net or if it's a
double double net you have very little
going out those are pretty simple to
determine you know but you know
everybody's got their own situation so
for the average listener right now it's
1835 year 18 to 35 year old man uh let's
just say they're working like a standard
W2
job what would your piece of advice be
for them if they're just trying to save
up and buy a house right now you need to
number one get yourself on a budget okay
now is the time to be smart and not
waste any money if you don't need it
don't buy it don't use it and save your
money Now's the Time to stash your cash
because that's going to get you some
strength you also you know if you I mean
I always promote young people that don't
have a lot of money if they if if if it
fits their life they should seriously
think about getting a real estate
license because if you get your real
estate license even if you don't use it
okay or maybe use it once in a while I
mean real estate's great you know you
can have a real estate license you got
you have a real estate license not
anymore well they took it away yeah gave
it up in California I mean but when you
were younger you had a real estate
license if you wanted to buy a property
for
yourself
you automatically you're representing
3% is your commission well now there's
that big class action lawsuit though oh
see that yeah it won I know a bit of a
side tangent here but a group of people
got together and said that it was um uh
price fixing price fixing fixing why
can't I say that price fixing from the
National Association of Realtors that
the seller was now obligated to pay a
fixed commission to a buyer's agent to
be able to list on the MLS and they won
and it was a billion multi-billion
dollar
lawsuit I don't understand I mean you
have a listing agreement you agree to
pay x amount uh percent when you list
your property and of course it gets it
can can be negotiated by the time you do
the deal but if the agent sells the
property for less money he gets less
commission if he sells for more prop
money he gets more commission I mean I
don't understand where the conflict is
the seller has to pay the buyer's
commission and for the for the for
agents to remain competitive and and
show the house they're they're looking
at at the commission and they're saying
well this property pays me 3% and this
property over here they're paying 1% I'm
not going to show that property I'm
going to show the 3% that's been going
on forever there are agents out there
that they'll go after the ones that are
selling you know they won't take a
discount commission except these days
the agents are starving starving I got
Brokers that are willing to just throw
in a whole commission practically
accept a small fee just to get the deal
done okay typically you used to pay a
broker and Commercial maybe two or
three% I've closed deals recently for a
quarter of a point a half a point what
price
point deals you know so he's happy to
get something to come into his team just
to keep the money flowing plus he knew
if he didn't reduce his
commission I couldn't do the deal I need
when I do a deal the first thing I tell
the agent when we get somebody that
makes us an offer I want to see my net
sheet always ask don't be afraid to tell
the asent show me my net show me the
purchase the sales price show me the
commissions show me the closing cost the
title insurance the dock stamps show me
what my Net's going to be okay and then
if you can't get to the number you want
that's where you start negotiating you
start saying well I'll tell you what in
order for me to do this deal this is
what I do on a daily basis in order for
me to do this deal you go back to this
to the buyer and you say listen you need
to pick up the docs transfer stack trans
they call them doc stamps transfer tax
or you need to pick up the title costs
or maybe we'll split it or you need to
you know lower your commission down but
I tell them right off the bat this is
the net number I have to get to now it's
your job as an agent to figure out how
to get me to that net otherwise I'm not
a seller so people are working a lot
harder now because something's better
than nothing you know yeah but I
understand the whole lawsuit you're
talking about but um typically you know
it pays to be a real estate agent if you
if you're starting out because you still
can get a commission as the buyer okay
typically houses a listed with a five to
six% commission the buyer gets half the
seller gets half so if you qualify for
an FHA mortgage it's three and a half%
down if you're a real estate agent and
you 3% commission you only got to put a
half% down am I right y there you go
that's how you get in the door without
putting a lot of money down we were
talking before about mortality and how
you said like you know once you Eclipse
you know when you're nearing 60 years
old or when you Eclipse think about it's
natural how you just naturally start
thinking about things I want to know
maybe why why continue pushing for
wealth why continue pushing for all of
these things when there are others other
things in life maybe that you could be
missing out on such as physical health
which you said you been losing weight
you know and going out and traveling and
experiencing life in other ways rather
than just continually building a
business that's already extremely
successful why keep pushing I mean you
know because you got to keep moving on
in a different chapter in in the book of
life you know right now I got to
determine listen I don't I'm not I'm not
the type of person that wants to work
you know until the day I drop dead it's
not me I I want to see what it's like to
retire maybe enjoy my life I got a nice
big boat sitting in the water waiting
for me you know know but I also have to
think about and protect listen I
wouldn't be here today with all this
wealth if it wasn't for all my kids and
people that have helped me okay so I
have to come up with a plan that's going
to enable me to live out the rest of my
life
comfortably and also protect the people
that helped me get where I'm at today
mainly my children and make sure they
have enough uh wealth so they can keep
growing if they choose or be protected
you got to protect the people that took
care of you that's that's a fact life
but that is a lot of protection I think
for a lot of people even giving a
million dollars to their kids would be
like hey they're they're set you know
most of my kids are already
multi-millionaires but you know they're
hungry and they're you know I mean I
look at I I think back you know my my
oldest son is 38 I believe he's 20 or 39
he's like 19 years younger than me um I
think back back and I remember when I
was his age you know I pretty much had
what he has now okay and he has an
extreme hunger and
desire to go to the level that I'm at
and he has every right to okay and so
does all my kids um you know they all
have the the right they've earned the
right to grow their wealth in their life
as much as they want just like I did
they learned from me so so you know I
have to just make sure that they're set
up to be able to do that and if they
have a problem call me I'll be on my
boat so what's your what's your plan
with that it to be able to set them up
in positions where they can take their
advantages that they have and pursue the
lives that they want how will you adjust
your own life to be able to set them up
for that I mean the ideal situation for
me I think is take the best assets I got
which they are Partners in some assets
take the best assets I got that are
really long-term assets assets that you
should probably think about keeping for
the long term and incorporating them as
partners so if I'm gone nothing changes
basically their Partners uh and that's
the end of that they you know they keep
keep getting the same income they've
been getting and then my share will be
distributed accordingly you know between
wives and my wife I say wives are it's
just it's just something you're not
telling us there only one room now only
one wife believe me yeah uh and um you
know it'll all work out I'm seeking out
the best legal advice I can get and
trying to get the plan going because you
know I am afraid I'm getting older now
and I need to have a plan in place I can
walk out this door right now and drop
dinner on your doorstep you got
insurance I do we renewed our policy we
have like what they call a master policy
that covers all our properties insurance
is doubled in Florida you know making us
pay for the h you know what's crazy so
you know what's crazy we can put this in
here you know what's crazy is that I was
shopping around for insurance insurances
lately because I really want to
consolidate everything right right now I
have like five different policies with
different carriers it was a nightmare to
coordinate so I'm bundling everything
together and three insurance companies
said they would no longer insure
California properties they're done they
say nope we hit our quota we we're not
taking on anymore and these are
companies that like four years ago no
problem they're not insuring California
they basically said you have to stick
with what you have because you're not
getting anything else and I called in my
my existing insurance carrier and said
no uh you're you're you're grandfathered
in but we're not taking on any new
polies why do they not want California
they say it's unprofitable and it's too
expensive to ensure they're losing money
on M on californ because wildfires uh
property damage crime uh houses are
costing so much money to rebuild
construction cost are through the roof
pering Z capital of the world yes
there's so much risk for insurance
companies in specifically California
Florida I believe is just a lot of
natural disasters California is just
like political reasons zoning there's
there's so much trouble with that they
they want a policy it's
wild and and lawsuits are getting
ridiculous now it's getting way out it's
crazy how do you think we can reform
that or do you think it won't the
problem is is that the insurance
companies settle too quick you know
legal fees go through the roof it's a
mess you know and a lot of it is a fraud
has a lot to do with it you know but the
courts are just too generous you know I
mean listen if somebody has a legitimate
claim I believe they should be paid okay
but it's gone nuts it's gone totally
crazy now I think we just settled the
claim for a slip and fall for half a
million dollars and I I honestly because
the concrete when I bought it was
already painted in a walkway area and we
didn't know we didn't you there's
nothing wrong with that and somebody it
was raining and a person slipped and
fall and they got half a million dollars
the insurance company just didn't want
to fight it and it was
much damage to the person I mean it's
just totally crazy what a legal system's
going with from their perspective it's
pay half a million now limit the loss or
spend half a million fighting the thing
over years and then let's just say they
win and you're right then it's can I
collect half a million dollars from the
person who slipped and fell no so what
am I going to do just just pay it now
versus spend years of this insurance
companies make more money than anybody I
mean all the Hurricanes that we had the
damage we had in
Florida yeah paying out on all line of
that so what do they do they just went
and doubled all our rates so now they're
going to recapture all the money that
they spent in the hurricane insurance is
a good business you should think be G
Going Insurance business I mean it's
tough right now it is very hard to be in
real estate with the cost of insurance
and the rates being where they're at
it's not a good time to just say I want
to be in real estate you got to find a
deal and when you find that deal you got
to L all the out of it I mean Now's
the Time to look look all right do your
homework look for a deal but lowball it
okay because times are not good in real
estate that's just a fact it's a fact
and rents are staying steady right now
but they're way they're way expensive
rents are way out of the whack right now
but because nobody's buying homes that
creates a lot more renters and keeps a
lot more renters in the market so multif
family is staying wrong except if you're
an adjustable rate yeah but as far as
your your income goes multif family is
very strong because people aren't buying
houses listen I have no crystal ball
like I said I cannot
understand why the
homebuilders that's when you know the sh
hit the fan keep watching the news keep
watching the home builder stocks I can't
imagine how these guys cuz all these
homes that they go on they develop a
thousand unit you know
they doing that they're doing that down
the street when they started they
started years ago with the planning on
that their budget everything was years
ago when times were great now the same
person they thought how much in the
house is going for down down here the
new developments uh in the new one that
they're building I think they start at
17 17 and that's yeah
17 now if somebody goes out let's say
they do have the 20% down because that's
like a jumbo loan right yeah all right
so 17 is340 ,000 down these people still
got to borrow about a million
four when they first plan on selling
these homes to people you know where
they got to carry a loan for a million
four the rates with three okay what's
that about 40 Grand a year now it's
double that people don't qualify they
don't qualify they're not going to be
able to sell the homes well here's what
I'm finding in terms of the rental
market for housing it seems like a lot
of sellers who don't want to sell
because they locked in that 3% mortgage
they're putting their home up on the
market market for rent and because their
cost is so low and because they've got a
such a low basis they don't need to rent
it for that much so I'm finding rents at
least here in Vegas are really coming
down same with uh Los Angeles a lot of
protection the only protection it's
either keep the house and wait for
better of times to come and rent it out
to pay my mortgage pay my taxes pay my
insurance that's how a lot of people got
through 2008 all the successful people I
saw said I'm not going to sell on this
down Market I'm just going to rent it
out and ride this out and those people
came out so far ahead right they didn't
have to sell they didn't sell who's
buying your properties now is it true
that black rock is going through these
these big institutional investors are
buying up all the houses what's your
experience I believe it's the opposite
from what I'm seeing is all the big
shots like Black Rock to BU up all those
homes they're now selling them they're
getting out because they don't cash flow
I mean to my knowledge all the big shots
are selling right now I just tied up two
deals uh well hopefully tomorrow I'll be
on a conference call and I I'll get the
deal finalized I just bought two
apartment building some very very large
company um you know and uh I believe I'm
buying them really right I'm buying them
for
probably I believe 30% less than what
they would have received six months or a
year
ago so how much are you paying for
them I can't tell you there still people
out there I didn't sign a contract yet
but I believe I'm buying it for 30% less
than what the market would have paid the
reason why I'm getting him in a discount
because there is no
Market what I'm buying and I always had
the advantage I can compete with Wall
Street when I say Wall Street I mean the
REITs and the Big Shot black stones and
black rocks and all these big shots I
can compete with them because of terms I
don't have anybody to answer to I can
come in with the strongest terms you
ever seen I could I could sign a
contract and say okay give me three days
for due diligence where everybody else
has boards to answer to and all these
layers of approval they have to go
through and all this I got the money
okay and I could go I can tell my sons
listen go out there and inspect that
property they'll walk every single
apartment they'll go through every
income and expense item and in three
days we can knock it out I can go hard
with a million bucks that's the only
that's the The Edge I have by being you
know no one to answer to and have my own
company um so I'm starting to see the
deals coming trust me all the deals
there was these all these beautiful
complexes around my neighborhood in
Tampa Bay area that were up for sale all
right and they were all you know they
like 180 a door 200 a unit the rents are
only like 1,600 a month, 1700 a month
the numbers didn't make sense none of
them sold none of them there was like 10
of them all these big fancy complexes
with 10 100 200 units in them they're
not getting they they couldn't sell now
the sellers got to go back and rethink
well we missed the market just like I
missed the market on that house now what
do we do do we keep the property or do
we discount it lower the price and get
the hell out you know it depends it
depends on the ownership structure of
the property are they partners is their
debt coming due soon uh you know loans
come due balloon payments come due you
know it all depends on what kind of loan
you have but now with the new insurances
uh rates going through the roof people
are taking loss they they're bailing and
then you know also the taxes are
actually what I'm finding I'm learning
more about taxes property taxes is like
right now the new tax bills came out
right they call trim notices they come
out and they tell you what your taxes
are probably going to be and they due in
January you do get a discount if you pay
them in November or December you know
and then January and then then you get
charged late fees if we pay them in
February or March oh no they do by March
they good for January to March anyway
long story short the counties are basing
the
values on last year that's dangerous
last year because you pay taxes in the
rear okay when I pay my tax bill my tax
bills are millions of dollars okay when
I pay my tax bill that I get a discount
paying in fact this month I have till
the end of the month but those tax bills
have all been jacked up based on what
they their praise value they did back in
January so now here I am I'm not making
that kind of probably aren worth that
but my tax bills are G up a lot so I got
taxes against me I got insurance against
me I got high interest rates against me
it's all the pieces that fall into the
puzzle of disaster do you like it seems
like you kind of like the stress about
it though there's there's an aspect
where you see it as a bit of a challenge
cuz that for me done with it but you
know I don't know likees all I know is I
can't sit back and cry about it and I
have to think about what can I do that's
logical that makes sense to improve the
position I'm in now or deal with the
stuff that's happening to me you know
wherever it is's a problem you have to
come up with a solution in life I don't
care what it is you know whether it's a
any problem you got in life you got to
come up with a solution it's just like
you know if you can't get along with
somebody you know what the solution is
get the hell away from them
simple i' I've been trying is right here
you won't go away change a lot change
your
number I like I like that theme that's a
theme that we've been seeing like over
and over again I feel like on the
podcast which is like it doesn't matter
who fault it is but it's only your
responsibility to improve the situation
that you're in that's it you know it's
like all these countries aren't getting
along leave each other alone you stay in
your space and stay in my space and fine
you can't get along then just leave us
alone I do it all the time with people
you know if I can't get along with
somebody or I feel like they're
detrimental in my life I just don't deal
with them how often does that happen do
you cut somebody off I cut people off
whenever it's necessary and it could be
family members could be anybody life is
too short to have any kind of what we
call in the hood is drama save the drama
for your mama because she's the only one
that's going to put up with it but what
sort of thing would would make you cut
someone off like that I mean if they're
doing something that's going to hurt me
or anybody in my my world you know I got
to leave you alone listen you know
honestly I don't even have any hard
feelings but I've noticed in my life my
life stays peaceful because I don't
associate or deal with anybody who
disturbs the
peace okay that's the way I
live but how do you set the emotions and
the ego aside and base all of your
decision- making strictly off of what is
practical and logical how do you do that
because a lot of people people are ran
by their emotions right and like by
other people saying no you should stick
with this person you should keep this
person in your life this is what Society
is saying I give people chances you know
people screw up I've screwed up okay we
all screw up all right but then you have
to look at the severity of the screw up
I mean if somebody keeps screwing up you
know listen I got no time to go
backwards I got to move up okay this
elevator only goes up I'm not going down
so you got to you you got to you got to
stay away from negative people your life
you got to stay away from people that
don't have the same interest and desires
that you have uh you know and and you
know listen I don't care how rich
somebody is I'm very very my closest
friends in the world don't have nowhere
near the money I got okay it doesn't
matter money when it comes to
interacting with other humans you either
get along with somebody and you you live
in in in peace together or you don't and
if you come across people who are
negative or you know could cause you
issues because you know Association you
get a lot of trouble just by being
associated with the wrong people you
know I mean it's a fact you want to keep
you gotta look at your whole world and
keep all the bad stuff out of your world
focus on the positive and focus on
getting ahead focus on your family you
know you think you learned some of that
with your experiences in the mob which
was what you alluded to earlier in the
mob they fired me you know they did me a
favor you know they that you they fired
you I was young and they wanted me to go
out and do collections
the whole story about they wanted me to
go collect from a guy who was a dead
beat and then they wanted me to hurt the
guy I'm not a violent person I mean yeah
I'll defend myself but you know I can't
just go out there and and and you know
and be that type of person to hurt
people you know because they they know
just like you know they borrowed his
money and then he didn't pay him well
how's Hur him going to help he's sure
hell going be able to pay you hurt him
that I feel like is that sending a
message though they wanted me to send a
message that's all it is it's not like
to get the money back I feel like oh
yeah he got hurt and is firing someone
too nice for the mob say it again isn't
firing too nice for the mob I feel like
if the mob had a problem with well they
didn't really let me in it was like a
test it was a test and I test you're not
ready for this type I ended up getting
the money I got the money you keep it no
I would be I the money I don't know was
like 16 17 I mean no I mean I got him
his money that he wanted me to collect
but I did it in such a crazy logical
sensible way that they couldn't relate
to that cuz all they knew is you owe me
money you don't pay me I'm going to hurt
you well maybe there's another way of
getting the money maybe we can look into
the whole picture I don't you remember
the story I took the guy's car and I
fixed it up and I sold it and I got the
money and we all should live happily
ever after and it was a logical
intelligent thing to do but they didn't
think that way you know they like they
they they they Thrive off of the
intimidation and the fear and I don't
want to be part of that that's how they
keep their power though isn't it of of a
bit of that intimidation dark world and
I don't want to be part of it how active
are they today I don't know I don't want
to know I don't think they're nowhere
near as active as they were when back in
the day the government is really you
know I think takes a really close look
at it especially with technology these
days you can't really hide anything you
can't hide money you can't even hide
your conversations anymore if they they
really want to hear you so you know I
think it's gone down but you know
they're still around but they're they're
not out there like they used to be you
don't see them hanging out and each
other in the streets like they used to
be you know and uh they're all trying to
keep a a cover because they see when you
expose
yourself you're exposing yourself to the
the criminal justice system they're
going to come after you so why would you
expose yourself you don't like God eat
all that bragging I mean you're a
bragging listen you never want to mess
with the government they have unlimited
resources to come after you
unlimited and they take it personal too
you know because it's a career you know
so I don't want no part of anything
that's criminal I try not to if I even
think somebody's criminal uh with the
exception of Jack that's a real low
different level um it's more like Petty
I don't want nothing to do anything
that's that's any kind of criminal
activity I don't want no problems with
nothing I just want to do what I'm doing
leave me alone and you know you think
some of that mob mentality that you were
like a product of when you were younger
is still bleeding through to who you are
today I know how to deal with it but I'm
not like a bully but I'm sure you
learned some life lessons and stuff like
that you learn how to try to get along
with everybody whether you're a bum on
the
street or you're a big shot everybody's
a human being okay and I try to relate
to everybody on their level okay you
know so we have that connection you know
if you walk around like I'm better than
everybody then you know what the hell
how's that going to be productive you
know I mean you know not in a big
picture I rather people like to deal
with me and if I have a problem with
somebody I'm going to sit down and try
to work out their problem because you
know there's two sides to every story
sometimes you got to put yourself in the
other person's shoes I've had people you
know say things to me that they felt
were unfair that they were treated by me
unfairly well I'll tell you what you got
your side I got my side all you got to
do in life with another human being is
find a Common Grounds where you're both
satisfied and typically money solves
that problem you know the only problem
we have in this world today is you know
religion how how does money solve the
problem how when have you used money
money is what makes everybody money is
what what what your life is all
controlled by money I mean honestly you
need money to survive you need money to
do everything in life you can't live
without money okay you need money to eat
you need money to live you need money
controls but how can you use money to
solve a personal matter like argument
between two people what are you talking
about you ever heard of
divorce do people couples do it all the
time yeah but it doesn't solve the
relationship money doesn't there's no
more relationship the money you give
somebody some money and you separate the
relationship and you move on and live
your own life the way you want right
okay it makes him feel it makes him feel
better like if if he feels like you got
something that deal you need just get
kicked in the curb you know if I say to
you listen I don't want to deal with you
no more okay but we have had some
history together or you do have some
sort of you feel you have some sort of
Rights or something like that all right
here's some money have a nice life you
go your way I go mine we all live
happily ever after
like imagine someone cuts you off in
traffic and there's like ah here's 100
bucks wouldn't that be like oh wow yeah
I just made $100 like that would kind of
solve it's not though no it's true I
think it's very true you could solve
anything like that I mean you know if
somebody cut you off and there was no
damage done you didn't do it on purpose
you know and the person apologizes
that's being human yeah you know but if
he hit your car and you didn't want the
insurance claim because your rat's going
to go up and you know damn well that
that damage isn't really that much it's
only you have it fixed for 100 bucks and
the guy gives you say 150 for your
trouble whatever it's a good way to just
you know people just need to come
together find a meeting point meeting
ground and and and make things happen to
where it's peace I don't believe in
violence I don't I cannot believe in
this day and age with all the technology
we got with all the space travel we're
doing and all the uh electric cars and
your Teslas were still hurting each
other you would think violence wouldn't
even play a role in the human society
anymore it's not logical how is
destroying a
country helping anyone how is it helping
I don't think many people are as logical
as you look at life it seems like
emotion really runs the majority of
people out there what is what is oh
let's get down to it what's Russia gonna
have if they totally destroy Ukraine
they're GNA have a country that's
totally worthless garbage I hate to see
destruction of Real Estate
when you're in real estate all right
listen if the building's got to go and
it's falling apart and you got to knock
it down like you do the casinos here
that's understandable that's logical
you're going to build something new but
to go in and Destroy families and
people's lives and and things that have
been existing and for many many years
where is the reason in it where's the
reason that's not solving the problem
you know crushing somebody is not the
way to do it you know it's better you
know you find Common Ground find a
solution that works for everybody
violence it's not humanly it shouldn't
be in part of our society anymore I'm
sorry I mean I I it sounds nuts that I'm
saying that but I don't feel that
anybody should have any reason you know
I mean yes the person that if you're
defending yourself well that person that
you're defending yourself from shouldn't
be violent to begin with so you wouldn't
have to defend yourself I mean you know
we got a lot of issues in society we
need to focus on you know taking all the
violence people that we do have and
trying to either correct them or do
something with them but we need a
nonviolent Society I think you know I've
been to other countries and it's scary I
mean the governments are are very some
of the governments these countries are
very dangerous I mean you know you go to
China you say the wrong thing in China
you're in big trouble come on I think
the difference is that you and I feel
like Graham and I are probably pretty
similar it's just too logical I know you
know what I mean you can't relate to the
average person it's like I mean we're we
are animals we are driven by our
animalistic instincts and our emotions
and our desires got to control them and
stuff like that this our brain should
take control over our emotions it should
100% okay we have brains that have
created all this stuff you know how this
the world has progressed in the past 50
years alone I mean it has gotten better
right we still have in many I think for
a lot of people all it takes one one
trigger and people lose their temper and
they could do one thing that they throw
their lives away I think unfortunately
I'm sorry to say people may not like me
saying it I think religion when it's
when it's taken to the extreme number
one I don't care what anybody believes
in you could sit in a corner and stand
on your head as long as you're not
bothering nobody if you think that
that's your life and you enjoy it it
makes your life peaceful or content then
be my guest I don't care but when you
feel like you have to force your beliefs
on someone else okay and you're willing
to go to violence to do it you know I
mean a lot of these religions they're
practicing uh Traditions that went on
thousands of years ago we're a lot
different human beings than we were a
thousand years ago okay let's get real
now you know I mean you know it's fine
you want to believe in something see I'm
also with me you got to prove to me you
got I'm I'm the type of person I need to
be proven okay you can tell me this
person exists or this exists and that
exists prove it I want to see it what do
you you believe in when it comes to that
I just believe that we're all here for
this little amount of time on this Earth
all right we're
intelligent and we need to keep
progressing to be you know get along
everybody should get along all right
we're all not going to be Filthy Rich
all right yes the world does need people
to be landscapers the world does need
people to do all SS of jobs and that's
the world we live in but everybody
should be treated with respect okay if
everybody just respect each other and
everybody got their own space and
respect the world be a perfect place I
don't know why we can't accomplish that
you know it just doesn't make sense we
got AI
now ai it's all I hear about is ai ai ai
at the convention I'm at ai ai ai let me
talk to AI you know it's funny pretty
soon um I think actually are we doing
the sponsor where they they're able to
take your face and then make that into a
video and they take your voice and face
and'll look just like you so you could
be speaking right here as AI we could do
the whole thing you train the the model
and we could just have a conversation
with you and you can control what I'm
saying there's a podcast out there I'm
not going to say which podcast but the
audio got messed up we've already posted
it it did very well for us and we ran
the entire audio track through Ai and
then an AI voice regurgitated in more
clarity the entire transcript of the
podcast matching each person's voice so
if you guys want to try to figure out
which one that is oh I don't even know
which one it is could you could you say
it and we'll bleep it out sure it was uh
Justin Waller no the entire podcast was
AI are you serious we use AI on the iced
coffee hour no I had no idea yep it's
all AI it's not AC that's one podcast
not gonna say which one it is yeah last
night told me he can do a book on my a
book he said I can write a book totally
with AI yep I me simple that's why a l
had no idea the entire thing why how bad
was because we had buzzing so like you
could remove sounds that are input
actually and recorded into the track so
like a lot of the times I don't know if
you guys won't care about this but it's
kind of interesting when we record in
the iced coffee hour a lot of the times
there will just be random interference
so for example if we have a battery pack
that's sitting on one of the cables
these are analog cables that we record
all the audio into if you have something
like a power cord that's resting on top
of it it for some reason just makes
buzzing start to appear so you can have
like as we're talking and you can remove
that as long as you have a transcript of
the words and a general idea of the way
that someone's voice sounds you just
read it with AI and then spit it out
with AI again and it can work question
is insan are you real or are you AI
That's a good are are any of us real or
AI if anyone's AI here I would say it's
probably you you're AI I know yeah I
know we do this with he just a
artificial I know we do this with some
of our some of our Tik toks so what
we'll do with AI and this is incredible
is uh Josh who runs our Tik toks some
sometimes wants a good hook in the
beginning cuz you got to get people in
the first like second and he'll say
Graham could you just repeat into the
mic say this one phrase and I'll say it
and then what he could do is he could
take my face and make it look as though
I'm saying exactly that on the Tik Tok
as a hook even though I've never said
that on camera before I don't even
realize when I'm doing it or when I'm
not sometimes I could slightly point it
out if you if I know the specific one
you could kind of tell but if you don't
pay attention I would have no idea it's
scary insane we've used it for titles of
videos we've used it for guest research
before we shoot with someone we just ask
AI like what are some interesting topics
we can talk to so some of them are good
we we used to online dating
now ai now so that's dating in AI his AI
is going to somebody else's Ai and now
they're going to have ai together oh w i
i want to know this is this could get me
in a lot of trouble but I'm just going
to say it we're talking about being
logical rational that's how you go
through all of like life's problems now
you know I have had a girlfriend before
and when she comes at me when she came
at me with you know certain issues a lot
of times I would try to solve them I
would be like here this is the rational
and logical way of solving this issue
and that would not yield the best
benefit usually that would really upset
her so how do you navigate
relationships let's say listen I'm going
to get in a lot of trouble for it this
but it doesn't work with women only
works with business and numbers and
Deals if it has to do with a
relationship with a woman you could
throw logic out to God damn window okay
this is anecdotal guys this is not you
know General broad sweep you know it's I
mean you know I just tell my you know
when you're in a relationship basically
I I'm going to be married 20 years next
month when you're in a relationship you
finally figure out basically the
simplest way to deal with your wife is
to just agree with her agree with her
but what if it's something you really
disagree with you just don't want that
whatever it might be do you still agree
or like when do you decide when to push
back I don't know I typically
agree unless it means it going to cost
me a lot of money I'll cry poverty but
uh but you're fine bending your
principles of like it had to be
something really serious I mean you know
listen you know every relationship is
different you know I mean me and my wife
are 100% opposite there is not one thing
in common between me and my wife and how
did it work out in the first place you
know because maybe being opposites
really works you know um I don't know
like you know my wife's a lot younger
than me so she likes to you know do
everything a younger person like to do
she likes to party she likes to you know
have a good time which I used to do but
I'm older now she likes to go running
she likes to work out she plays
tennis you know she she worries about
things that I could care less about what
we're eating or you know we're opposite
in every possible way you can
imagine okay and somehow it works what
bonded you two together then um was it
physical attraction and then everything
else of course well for me it was
physical
I it was physical for me and she saw
opportunity with me you know but um you
know I mean I don't know all I know is
that you know
we've been accepting each other and
putting up with each other for almost 20
years and um you know her world is
totally different than mine totally
different we don't work together uh I
don't get involved with uh her world
with the house with the kids or the
day-to-day stuff uh you know and and I
focus on making money and we enjoy a lot
of time together what do you guys do
together oh I mean we got you know we go
out on a boat we'll take the boat all
over to Bahamas we'll take trips
um you know we do whatever you know go
out to dinner we go to parties whatever
I we have a social life and um but um
total opposites you know can you see me
playing tennis come on so so you just
agree with the the wife in the situation
but she also agrees with me it's like
she's got her department and I got my
department okay she's not going to come
in and say okay listen you need to sell
that hotel it's going to happen she's
not going to you know she's not going to
cross into a world that
Sheed no I don't recall her ever like a
house she see something stressing you
out we just bought her sister a house
okay cuz we sold a hotel in Fort
Lauderdale her sister's moving back home
she's taking over over all my Beach
property hotels and uh we need to find a
sister a house so you know to me I told
my wife to handle it well of course that
didn't work so good but you know CU her
sister wanted one thing she wants to
another it's not good enough for my
sister blah blah blah anyway long story
short I told my wife you know listen do
whatever you feel best as far as a house
is is um I go along with you know so why
not rent the house this is the one for
1.2 yeah um renting a house is just you
know I don't know just if I would have
rented the house it probably a house
like that in that neighborhood probably
would have cost me at least um
six seven Grand a month probably yeah
it's a big house I mean the house is
like 4500 square feet she's got four
children uh you know and we're pretty
much on the level where you know and a
sister's like one of my sister's my
daughter basically I raised like my
daughter okay so you know when it comes
to your kids it does get emotional with
real estate because you want your kids
to live somewhere nice all my kids live
in big beautiful homes which they're
entitled to they deserve it you know so
you know she should have her own home
and uh you know renting her house would
be very this is more of a permanent
thing too it's not like a temporary
situation typically I would always rent
yeah you know uh if she's living here
for a year or there for two years yeah
rent her house but in this situation
we're trying to get her stable and you
know more permanent so we bought the
house and I got a good deal on it I'm
happy with the price we paid it was on a
market of a million5 we paid a million
two and it came fully furnished and
everything really quality and everybody
live happy ever after and I agreed with
my wife on the house that she thought we
should buy so we're all happy seems like
you really don't like having lasting
issues or things that you're not content
with like you just like to all right
let's let's figure it out let's move on
fine that's good I got every day I got
different things fires to put out I'm
constantly waking up every morning
putting fires out okay figuring out what
are the problems right now that we're
facing what do I got to do to solve them
you know and uh that's what I do for a
living managing a portfolio how did you
meet your wife family was the caretakers
in probably the most dangerous building
in Oakland California at the time that
nobody wanted to buy I used to buy all
the rough stuff that nobody else wanted
because that's the only place I can get
in you know um no competition cheaper
price you know so she lived in a very
very tough building and I bought it it
was a foreclosure and it was 14
apartments that stretched a whole street
city block and
um family like the caretakers there you
know which nobody else lived in the
building but them at the point when I
bought it there was nobody else living
but them you know and I could have told
him to leave but you know I met her
grandfather and her family and then you
know she was very young we weren't
dating you know when she was very young
but I met her family and the family
started helping me fix up the building
her grandfather was a roofer oh let's
fix the roof but he couldn't fix the
roof while he was there because there
was no money to fix the roof well I came
in I bought the building I got some
money for materials and to pay him some
labor he started help me fix the roof or
you know when you marry in Mexican you
inherit 15 family members it's just the
way it is is and they all work for me
they all help me you know accomplish a
lot of things so you know next thing you
know we're fixing up all the apartments
we're painting them we're cleaning them
the women are cleaning the guys are
painting we're fixing this we're doing
that we're renting them out to Section 8
and we uh got that building turned
around I paid $250,000 for that building
14 units you do to ma what's that 20
grand a door yeah less than that I
probably put like five back then not
even a few grand a door into them I sold
a place for a million bucks eventually
um but it was very dangerous place but
we cleaned up the area too and you know
we used our management skills to make it
a garbage to gold and uh you know and
then as she got older you know we um we
you
know you just stayed close with her with
her and her family and stuff like that
family became very close to me because
we were they work for me we work
together every day you know and then she
matured into a young woman and um you
know we had the attraction and we got
married and um but like when would when
did you ask on a first date like how did
that even come up in a conversation
where you said hey she actually pursued
me she did yeah she'll deny it but she
pursued me I remember I I kind of
remember when I seen a twinkle in her
eye we finally got the building all
rented and my partner I had a partner
then too he didn't want to buy the
building he was afraid to but I told him
listen I can handle it and then I had
him come back and take a second look
after we got rid of all the criminal
activity around there and stuff anyway
got the building rented the building had
a laundry room and my partner even
though he had all these millions of
dollars he got some kind of personal
thrill of me and him going
around all right in his big fancy
Mercedes whatever he was driving that
day and taking the money out of the damn
laundry machines yes bags are quarters
he loved it and I loved it too because I
didn't have much money and half the
money was mine so we it was like a
tradition you know we go around all our
buildings we had you you know a few some
were his some were mine some were ponds
whatever anyway we go around one day
every other week and we collect all
these bags of money and we take them to
the bank and put them in the machine
they count them up
and you know we have some cash you know
whatever deposit whatever anyway the
long story short I remember I seen a
twinkle in her eye because let's face it
I was very poor back then and she was
very poor um when she saw me carrying
those bags of
money that's what did
I think
so one day I dropped the bag and the
quarters were everywhere all these kids
in the rough neighborhood were and
that's what spared she saw that came
down and protected me was she picking up
quarters too yeah but she was giving
them to me and you know listen we both
came from a very very tough place and
very very poor place and um we struggled
together for a while but it was great
you know we made it that's cool that
you've you've acquired all of this
wealth with her you know what I mean
like I feel like you don't see that a
lot it's more of a rare thing where you
got this like you know I acquire it and
she spends it but the age difference you
know with the with the wealth and
everything you know everybody's
different it worked for us you know it
doesn't work for everybody but it works
for us and we you know she's helped me
raise you know children from a previous
I helped raise her daughter I mean her
sister U you know it's been a a weird
situation but you know we both always
work together and try to do the right
thing for everybody is there anything
you guys disagree about
or for the most part do you just agree
with whatever she wants no I mean you
know we we disagree you know everybody
has in disagreements but nothing that
serious you know um you know she might
want to buy a $6 million yacht and I
rather find a bargain that's worth that
can probably for two that's worth maybe
three or four and yeah we have our
little disagreements but we always work
it out we always find a middle ground we
always find a meeting place you know
she's always going to complain about
what I'm eating but you know that's good
for me do you feel like you need to eat
a little bit healthier for her or is it
all just well I need to do I need to
take care of myself so I can you know do
of everybody else you know and then you
know she's the Drinker and I'm not the
Opposites I don't drink she drinks why
do you not drink it puts me to sleep
that's what that's what it does to
meod she she she starts drinking tequila
and she's drinking margaritas and all
she's ready to party baby you know me
I'm you know I mean is Andre huberman
did a whole podcast on the effects of
alcohol and he noted that in people's
brains you either have the type where
they drink and they get really energetic
or the people who drink and it puts them
to sleep and there's something in your
brain that you just process sleep me too
yeah me I go right to sleep it's
terrible it's really bad I Dr straight
to sleep it makes me not want to drink
but if you continue to drink you drink
then if you if you continue to drink
like past the point of being tired and
everyone's all excited then I can get
the energy but my default is just like I
slump and I just go on a couch if
there's a couch nearby and I fall it
might be 20 minutes where I have a bit
of energy bit more talkative but then
immediately after it sleep unless I just
keep drinking but yeah if you keep
drinking then you can get the energy but
like I got to go all right yes okay is
there anything else that there's to
anything else you want to cover okay the
real deal is this yes get ready because
what's the worst thing going to happen
it doesn't happen you got ready get
ready seriously deals are coming they
have to trust me I'm watching cap rates
going up now's the time to start looking
and watching and
lowballing all right there's no emotion
in doing a real estate deal if the guy
wants a million bucks offer him 750
that's the world we live in right now
and that's what you should be trying to
do because you may not take it now but
you'd be surprised a month from now you
might get a phone call or you might take
eight or 8150 you might say oh that's
still a good deal so be prepared because
we have to it has to to
happen when the bad happens that's
what opportunities knocking at the door
don't don't make sure you answer the
door don't just look at him on the ring
deal amazing thank you so much thank you
so much man I every time I see it puts a
big old smile on my face we can do this
easily another two hours three hours
just chat and unfortunately um I would
stay as long as you want but I got
people I'm obligated to well thanks Ben
really appreciate it thank you guys for
tuning in thanks for watching until next
time adios amigos and don't get go to
Ben Ma on YouTube and Ben's hotels and
ben.com you want to consult with Ben one
day